se cumple sin sobresaltos la tercera y
última jornada de las maniobras
militares chinas taipei había contado a
mediodía 59 aviones y 11 barcos de
guerra en la zona que se suman a los 150
del fin de semana unas decenas han
cruzado la línea media que es la
frontera oficiosa que fijó Estados
Unidos tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial
que Pekín nunca ha reconocido pero que
solía respetar el ejército chino
aclarado que con estos ejercicios ensaya
el bloqueo aéreo y marítimo de la isla y
el ataque quirúrgico a sus objetivos
clave y se ha esforzado mucho en
subrayar La amenaza en un vídeo colgado
en las redes sociales se ve a un
Bombardero sobrevolando supuestamente
las aguas de Taiwán en el que un piloto
aclara que los misiles están en buen
estado y recibe la orden de control de
disparar el vídeo se corta cuando el
piloto aprieta el botón de fuego pero
sin llegar a verse el vuelo del misil Y
es que no ha habido misiles en estas
maniobras en contra de lo que sí que
ocurrió en ordenó Pekín en verano pasado
tras la visita de Nancy pelosi la ex
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes la jornada también deja
la llegada de un buque destructor
estadounidense al mar del sur de China
Washington que había pedido calma y
sosiego a China durante toda la semana
ha enviado a su buque a las Islas
spradly que china reclama como copias
con la finalidad de completar lo que
pomposamente llama un ejercicio de
libertad de navegación y que cumple con
la finalidad de irritar a Pekín